les chambres avec plus de deux résidents
n'existait presque plus dans les chu cld
du québec puis le 21 juillet cette
lettre a eu l'effet d'un coup de poing
comme les listes d'attentes s'allongent
pour avoir une place d'hébergement
le ministère de la santé autorise la
réouverture des chambres multiples de ch
celle des jusqu'à quatre usagers par
chambre ça c'est les milieux
d'hébergement qui s'affairent des chants
brésiliens aux résidents moins de trois
mois après que la coroner géhanne kamel
et remis son rapport sur les décès
survenus au printemps 2020 dans les chs
lb québec prend donc une décision à
l'inversé de ce qu'elle recommandait
c'est un recul par rapport aux
conditions des choix à la veille des
élections ils veulent améliorer leur
chiffre leurs statistiques dans les
hôpitaux et le qu'est ce qu'ils font
mais ils mettent les aînés du québec en
danger c'est absolument scandaleux de
voir que mollement que mettre à risque
la santé encore une fois dû personnes
venues une accusation exagéré selon le
cabinet de la ministre marguerite blais
car les résidents des ch et celle des
sont vaccinés et des mesures de
prévention et de contrôle des infections
sont en place nous avons appris des
premières vagues assure la ministre est
une campagne de vaccination pour une
dose de rappel est en cours
la décision actuelle du gouvernement je
passe et la bonne dans le contexte où il
ya des milliers de personnes qui sont en
attente mais il faut bien réaliser que
ceci résulte de décisions
gouvernementales qui elles ne sont pas
appropriés osseuse la capitale nationale
par exemple il n'y a pour l'instant que
deux chambres multiples sont ici à
l'hôpital général de québec mais des
familles de résidents et des employés
espèrent qu'il n'y en aura pas davantage
je pense que si trop me fatigue
pas du tout bien celle on a des raisons
sanitaires
québec marc tels que les chambres
multiples sont autorisés seulement si
l'espace le permet mais cela n'évacue
pas tous les enjeux pour autant nous
n'avons plus de contamination comme de
puissants personnes dans une chambre on
nous met complètement ce qui tue ce que
sont des autres aux infections
nosocomiales comme le site issue la
mesure est en vigueur jusqu'à nouvel
ordre mais le gouvernement rappelle que
43 maison des aînés sont en chantier
qu'il rénove 23 ch et celle des vétustes
et que dans tous ses projets il n'y aura
que des chambres individuelles ici
alexandre duval radio canada québec